this is this is my Easter nest which
I've been lent by a technician Xena and
in it we've got two eggs
I've got here some weak hydric look
dilute hydrochloric acid and let's see
what happens and you can see is bubbling
and the bubbling is carbon dioxide being
released from the calcium carbonate
because you're forming calcium chloride
and carbon dioxide of course it's got
covered in bubbles which keeps the acid
away so may go slower than I want but
let's see what happens now the other
thing I wanted to do and this is quite a
daring piece of chemistry for me I want
to boil the egg so I've got some water
here which I'm heating up you can't find
a spoon so we're using the test tube
holder and all being well we can let the
egg into the water the I forgot to time
it so I know know when we started the
inside an egg as you know there is the
white and the yellow part the yolk and
both of them contain the proteins
proteins are long chains of smaller
molecules joined together so you can
imagine you have a chain of these
molecules perhaps a hundred units long
each of which is the so called amino
acid and these are linked together head
to tail to form a chain now what is
really remarkable about the protein is
that this chain folds up in a very
special way you see if I take this chain
and just drop it on the table and then I
do it again it will drop into completely
different shapes each time
what is remarkable about proteins and
people still don't really understand
completely is that every time this chain
of amino acids folds up in exactly the
same shape now what happens when we boil
an egg is that the white of the egg
which if you break an uncooked egg is
sort of semi-transparent and rather
sticky the in the medieval times people
use this to mix paints and paint it on
the walls but if you heat it up like
we're boiling the egg what happens is
that these chains start unwrapping and
linking together so you go from a
transparent material to a nice solid
white material the white material that's
like the weight of the egg which wheat
what is it about that linking up that
makes it go from transparent to white I
think what it is and I'm not absolutely
certain is that as they link together
they form larger and larger lumps and as
the lumps get bigger they become closer
in size to the wavelength of light and
when you have things that are similar to
size the wavelength of light they start
scattering it and so it all gets
reflected back and looks white and
that's probably why it happens it's sort
of cooking the egg without really
cooking it because we're using strong
acid which is beginning to look a bit
like my hair isn't it and
boiling of course is not the only way of
cooking eggs you can cook eggs by
subjecting it to really high pressure up
to perhaps 20,000 times atmospheric
pressure you can do this in special
apparatus which has a big piston and
compresses the water that the egg is is
in and if you compress the water and go
up to this high pressure the protein and
behaves just as if you're boiling it so
you can as it were cook your high in
your hard-boiled eggs when they're cold
and the advantage is that and as you may
know that when you have a hard-boiled
egg round the yolk you sometimes get a
black line where the compounds the
sulfur compounds that make the yolk
yellow have decomposed that give us all
the bluey black line but if you cook it
under high pressure you don't get this
nasty black line it looks really nice
and yellow so it's had about seven
minutes perhaps we give it a little bit
longer do you have a heat resistant
glove to pick up the boiling water look
beautiful thank you thank you I've got
the glove because I realized I haven't
got anything to pick up the hot water
with and let's look at the time we'll
switch off the Bunsen burner test tube
holders are not really designed for four
eggs but here we are
what I'm hoping to do is now to saw it
in half so we can see what's happened
inside it oops I think I think I've been
it's not quite pooped
that's not bad
the white has really gone white from the
sort of colorless part of the egg and
the yolk has begin began to solidify but
it's still a bit gooey if I stick my pen
in it you can see it still comes out a
bit gooey and the yellow color is due to
sulfur compounds in the egg it's not
sulphur itself
sulfur is yellow but the sulfur gives
this color and this is why when eggs go
bad rotten eggs
they smell so bad because the foul smell
from rotten eggs is caused by the
formation of hydrogen sulfide h2s just
like water but with two hydrogen's and
the sulfur instead of two hydrogen's and
an oxygen h2s is sulfurous in the same
group as water so h2s has some
properties that are similar to water but
it smells terrible I didn't expect it to
give like that some of its got green can
you see well I hoped that the egg would
just dissolve but without puncturing the
the membrane inside so all this stuff
would come out I think in my enthusiasm
with prodding it I must have punctured
the membrane it's quite interesting
because I've never seen an egg shell
reacting with acid before so I've
learned something by doing these
experiments even if you haven't
all right very good